[Music]
on this monday night telecom execs meet
with the feds the rogers outage dials up
demands for accountability and better
reliability the criticism over
compensation lack of competition
canada's three telecoms in a trench coat
and the potential consequences for the
proposed merger with shock record high
wait times we are in an incipient crisis
mode the emergency at overwhelmed and
understaffed ers ukraine's deep
disappointment with canada what ottawa
just allowed
and a notorious crime boss dies behind
bars the life of hell's angels leader
maurice boucher and his long list of
victims
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight tracy tong
good evening and thanks so much for
joining us the nationwide rogers
communications outage that took millions
of canadians offline lasted about 15
hours for most people but its impacts
are still being felt while the company's
ceo has apologized for the system
failure today many are calling into
question the cause compensation for
customers lack of competition in the
sector and network reliability those
issues among the topics of discussion at
a meeting between the industry minister
and telecommunications ceos our abigail
beeman has tonight's top story
canada has three telecoms and a trench
coat
a bad joke reflecting canadians bad
feelings about friday's massive rogers
outage and this country's lack of
options i said to them in no uncertain
terms this was
unacceptable full stop monday the
industry minister called tech execs to
the virtual table big players and small
ones too to talk about how to deal with
network reliability nationwide it feels
a little bit being called like being
called to the principal's office
what we really need is not just a
closed-door conversation but to continue
this national ongoing conversation about
the telecommunications system that we
have and the telecommunications system
that we want francois philippe champagne
told telecoms to enter into a formal
agreement to offer mutual assistance in
future outages provide emergency roaming
and have a better communications plan
within 60 days
i have demanded they do that and all of
them have agreed but how useful would
mutual assistance be champaign said he
spoke to bell and telus during the
outage they were happy to help but
couldn't since it was a rogers specific
problem we need to see solutions that
don't only orient towards
fixing these you know emergency
situations in short-term bursts but
rather building a system in which there
are more providers there is more
competition more talk of competition in
the wake of the outage puts the planned
26 billion dollar rogers shaw deal into
sharp focus there's much opposition to
the proposal including from new
democrats we're even more sure than ever
before that the merger is the wrong
thing to do imagine the outcome if shaw
had murdered the merger had gone through
then so many millions of canadians in
the west would have also been impacted
by this outage the ndp want a crtc
investigation of the outage which the
minister confirmed monday afternoon and
jagmeet singh says he'd support the
conservatives idea of calling rogers
executives to testify at a parliamentary
committee meeting what we have seen last
friday is total unacceptable so yes we
have to go deep inside the problems and
to fix it for long term as for the short
term rogers is promising to communicate
changes to prevent another outage saying
it was network maintenance that brought
down its system for frustrated customers
across the country much skepticism
remains as to whether anything will
really change abigail beeman global news
ottawa
those rogers customers frustrated over
the outage and the impact it's had on
their lives are now wondering about
being compensated and whether or not
they will take their business elsewhere
but as ann gaviola explains for the time
being consumers don't have many
alternatives
lara morgan's son fell at rugby practice
friday she was told he may have a
cervical spine issue and to call 9-1-1 i
tried to call 9-1-1
and my phone wasn't working and it was
quite terrifying calls to emergency
services interact payments and wi-fi on
the rogers network all were in chaos
this was no mere inconvenience for more
than 10 million people it was a scramble
to work to make or receive payments and
access urgent help for the outage to
happen on a day of art walk that was
really really hard a lot of us artists
make sales through our instagram stories
and use that platform and yeah we
couldn't use anything so it was
it was rough shares of rogers tumbled
monday along with consumer confidence
investors worrying about the rogers shaw
deal and frustrations rising over the
second widespread rogers outage in two
years rogers is offering compensation to
customers in the form of a credit that
will automatically appear on their next
bill for two days of lost service and if
it doesn't make the cut off for that
for some customers although we expect to
have all customers done by then it will
be on the following month's bill small
business advocates say that won't cut it
at minimum i would hope that rogers
would would deduct an entire month of
service for all of the different
utilities that were affected by the
outage our bills are expensive like i
think my bill probably is 275 dollars a
month
um i spend on my my phone bill and maybe
it's more maybe close to 300 so 5 10 off
it's kind of like
make a difference man do something you
know it's like a drop in the bucket a
class action suit was filed on behalf of
all rogers fido or chatter customers in
quebec or anyone in the province
affected by the outage and the public
interest advocacy center filed a letter
with the crtc the industry regulator
friday demanding an inquiry into the
outage calling for a look at whether all
telecom providers in canada should be
required to meet a baseline of emergency
planning and refund requirements and
what happened on friday is unacceptable
and we're committed to taking every step
within our control
to ensure it doesn't happen again
consumer advocates say because the big
three bell rogers and telus control
about 90 percent of the market a
potential shaw rogers deal could make
things even worse for customers one
company's tech problems should not lead
to a national economic problem for the
entire country frustrated customers can
vent to their member of parliament call
the company and ask for rogers loyalty
specialists and supervisors and if
they're still unhappy consider switching
to smaller independent providers ann
gaviola global news toronto
canada's premiers and territorial
leaders gathered in victoria bc looking
to push the federal government to
increase funding for health care
services and first nations today
premiers met with indigenous leaders to
discuss child welfare challenges and the
residential school legacy and spoke with
health professionals about the dire need
for more money to deal with staff
shortages exacerbated by the pandemic
we don't have enough people to fill the
vacancies in our private sector economy
and in our public sector economy because
it's not getting better it's getting
worse and although the band-aid
is welcomed we need stitches and we need
prosthetics and we need a whole bunch of
other equipment and people to make it
all work
richard sussman joins us now from
victoria richard this is the first time
in two years that premieres met face to
face it is clear they want more money on
the table so how likely is that and will
there be any strings attached
and it's a lot of money they want tracy
and it seems the federal government is
only willing to budge here if there are
strings attached at least details of
where the some odd 28 billion dollars
would go so the premiers here are
calling for an increase in the way
transfers work so right now the
provinces cover about 78 percent of
health care costs so the feds pay 22
percent the premiums would like to see
that go up to 35
but the federal government says they are
already earmarking money for different
provinces based on what they need and
they are uncomfortable with the idea of
this massive increase but the premiers
will continue to push as you heard there
from premier john horgan who chairs the
council of the federation it is crucial
to have the money to plan but there are
other things on the table here as well
health care is the crucial issue but
inflation has also come up as well the
premiers want to have a discussion
around how they can help canadians save
some money when there is huge pressure
and the last issue is the indigenous
issue you mentioned as well there is a
push from indigenous leaders to have the
premiers discuss the un declaration the
rights of indigenous people it's
legislation that was passed here in bc
and would like to see other provinces do
that as well so there's a lot on the
table the big decision will be made
tomorrow around exactly what the
premiers are pushing ottawa to do when
it comes to health care funding tracy
all right richard zusman in victoria bc
thanks for that report richard
and as canada's premiers plead for more
federal health care funding emergency
rooms across the country are struggling
with lengthy wait times and staff
shortages as jamie maraca reports
doctors are sounding the alarm saying
rising covet cases and a concerning new
variant could make things even worse
caroline pereira's kids are happy and
healthy now but last month her
two-year-old daughter struggled to
breathe on professional advice she
rushed her to this calgary er went to
the front and they told me to get to the
end of the line which was
out the door
and
that when a nurse was available they
would come and check her out 15 hours
later they finally saw a doctor
hospitals across the country say they're
short staffed and overwhelmed in ontario
weights have hit record highs over 20
hours last weekend in some hospitals the
president of canada's association for
emergency room physicians dr mike
howlett says the situation is beyond
critical there isn't
time
to debate and have discussions for
months and years we are in
an incipient crisis mode staff shortages
sick calls burnout backlogs and aging
population and covid have all helped
expose widening gaps during the pandemic
more families have been forced into ers
with many general practitioners stopping
in person consults strain our health
care system can't handle it's
starting to try to recover but it's not
being particularly successful
and it is extraordinarily vulnerable to
whatever is coming next a rising wave
from omicron's ba 4 and 5 variants is
pushing cases up again but experts say
they are also keeping an eye on another
newer mutation ba275
the world health organization has
already warned about the sub-variant
which was recently discovered in india
and now in the u.s the concern with
ba275 is the same concerns we have with
ba5 which is how is it going to behave
and how is it going to impact our
society over the next few months and
while this infectious disease physician
says it's not cause for alarm it should
be a warning to prepare and make
necessary changes to the system
immediately pereira also wants to see
action now i'm really terrified truly
really terrified that we will need
emergency services again like so many
families worried her kids won't get
timely care when they need it most jamie
morocco global news toronto
uconn is facing an historic wildfire
season with hundreds of fires already
burning across the territory according
to the yukon government more than 126
thousand hectares have burned this year
alone that is above the 25-year average
there have been 232 wildfires this year
including two sparked in the past day
one is burning on both sides of the bc
yukon border
crews are working overtime to slow a
growing wildfire crisis in california's
yosemite national park threatening to
wipe out the world's oldest giant
sequoias some of which are thought to be
more than 2 000 years old and can tower
more than 20 stories firefighters have
installed sprinkler systems to dampen
the ground officials say they have
avoided significant damage so far but
the fire threatening the park has
doubled in size
ukraine's new displeasure with canada
coming up the controversy over a
pipeline part
tens of thousands of protesters
occupying sri lanka's presidential
palace and prime minister's home are
refusing to leave as bitter
demonstrations continue over the
country's economic crisis that has
sparked shortages of food fuel and
medicine
thousands of sri lankans stormed the
residences of the president and the
prime minister on saturday demanding
both men step down sri lanka's president
says that will happen on wednesday the
country's prime minister says he will
stay on until a new government is formed
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky is
slamming the canadian government tonight
for its decision to return a sanctioned
turbine to germany warning russia will
view it as a manifestation of weakness
and calling on canada to reverse the
move redmond shannon explains the
controversy
more deadly airstrikes in ukraine's
second city of harkief many of the
survivors like valentina dazed and
traumatized
i think there were three or four hits
she says the last one made all the
rubble fall on me
in the donbass rescuers look for
survivors after the weekend's russian
missile attack that killed at least 30
people
ukraine says only civilians were in the
apartment building
russia says the block was being used by
ukrainian forces claiming it killed 300
of them in the attack
further south in mariupol the first
train cars depart its obliterated train
station since russia captured the city
in may
russian state tv filming this video a
sign of daily life operating in a new
normal under russian occupation but
ukraine's defense minister says nato
weapons will help his forces to launch a
counter-offensive to try and retake
parts of the black sea coast if those
weapons arrive more quickly if that is
done this would be feasible
but it needs to be done very very
quickly ukraine is also frustrated with
canada after ottawa bypassed sanctions
allowing a repaired turbine to be sent
from montreal to europe for use on the
russia-germany nordstrom one gas
pipeline we need to understand that
larger picture
and part of that larger picture is
that in a conflict
you need to make sacrifices ironically
it may be for nothing the pipeline was
shut down on monday for 10 days of
maintenance work there are fears russia
may keep it closed sacrificing the
massive income it gets from europe to
spite its western adversaries at this
point is not important for russia for
the revenues it is important because it
is a geostrategic tool eu countries have
paid russia an estimated 89 billion
dollars for fossil fuels since
february's invasion and there's no end
in sight redmond shannon global news
london
well we are getting a first look at the
deepest reaches of outer space ever
captured the first image from the
largest space telescope ever built has
just been unveiled it comes from nasa's
10 billion dollar james webb space
telescope
it's the deepest and sharpest infrared
image of the distant universe to date
four more images will be released
tomorrow and will include a planet from
outside our solar system
preparing for a painful visit with the
pope ahead reflections from residential
school survivors
the first nations communities of
muscules near edmonton will soon be in
the international spotlight when pope
francis begins his canadian visit the
pope plans to spend time with
residential school survivors at the site
of what was once one of the country's
largest institutions with thousands
expected to attend as heather urix west
explains the community is bracing for
emotional impact
with just two weeks until the pope
arrives in musculatus alberta the
community is working hard to prepare
for many this visit will be tough i'm at
peace and i'm really trying to be stay
strong and positive
trying to stay focused why he's coming
karen wildcat attended the ehrman skin
residential school for three years as a
child an experience she says that
upended her entire life as one of the
largest institutions of its kind in the
country the earmanskin residential
school operated from 1895 to 1975. those
who attended like bruce cutknife
remember it as a time full of trauma and
abuse the children were always crying in
the class
seeing a girl get beaten with a
yardstick and the teacher broke the
yardstick in half hitting her
took both hats of the yards to continue
you know hitting a child the pope is
expected to spend time with survivors of
this school and others like it and to
again apologize for the hand the church
had in this abuse we've heard a whole
range of emotions we've heard people who
are happy and
happy that he's coming and looking
forward to the apology and others who
are angry community leaders say they
know the visit will be painful 150
mental health workers will also attend
an historic but difficult moment of
acknowledgement and accountability that
survivors know will likely never come
again
heather urex west global news calgary
he was the murderer known as mom
next maurice boucher's long life of
violent crime
one of canada's most notorious criminals
died over the weekend maurice boucher
commonly known as mom boucher had been
battling cancer
the former hells angels boss was serving
a life sentence for the murders of two
prison guards mike armstrong reports
it's a time that looking back is almost
hard to believe this was maurice
mambouche at a court appearance for his
son boucher was the head of an elite
chapter of the hell's angels everyone
knew mambushi was a killer and he knew
everyone knew
he seemed to love it
quebec's biker war raged for eight years
more than 160 people were killed and it
made the man at the middle of it
infamous
bouchet led the nomads an elite chapter
of the hell's angels he got the nickname
mom because he was apparently like an
overbearing mother for a time he seemed
untouchable
he wasn't but when boucher was arrested
in 1997 he was already a household name
he wouldn't be behind bars for long and
his reputation was still growing
was put on trial for ordering the murder
of two prison guards the goal was to
destabilize the justice system
[Music]
he won the first round the jury in
bouche's original trial found him not
guilty
[Applause]
laughing wouldn't last
a second trial was ordered on appeal one
of the reasons jurors had been
intimidated bouche was found guilty the
second time around
he would spend the rest of his days in
prison but still plugged into organized
crime in fact still ordering murders in
2018 he had another 10 years tacked on
to a life sentence
now the reason boucher became what some
have called a folk here on quebec is
because most of the victims of the biker
war were criminals but not all
for journalists who covered those years
there are names of innocent victims that
are impossible to forget the prison
guards who were killed diane levine
the 11 year old boy playing in a park
killed when a jeep nearby was blown up
and eve albert the father of two gunned
down gassing up his car he was shot nine
times because he was mistaken for a
biker
if for a time boucher lived a life that
seemed to be above the law it didn't
last he spent his final two decades
locked up what did last is the pain he
caused
mike armstrong global news
montreal
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm tracy tong tonight's
your canada is saint mary's ukrainian
catholic church near alvina saskatchewan
thanks so much for being with us i'll
see you again tomorrow good night
[Music]